[Music]
foreign
I speak publicly through several
different mediums every day of my life
and you might think that those who wish
to be outraged by my comments would find
more than enough new fodder every day to
keep them satiated but somehow that is
not the case the outrage mob demands
even more reasons to be mad at me and so
they will not only sift through my daily
comments but they'll also dig through
everything I've said over the past 10
years to find more ammunition and this
creates a situation where nearly every
day I have factions of the outrage mob
screaming at me because of things I said
that day and then I have other factions
screaming at me arbitrarily over
something I said years ago so they'll
come banging on my door metaphorically
shouting hey remember this thing you
said on September 14 2016 and I'll say
uh no I actually don't that was a long
time ago I don't what are you talking
about and they'll say well here's what
you said and you said it and we're mad
about it seven years later
and I'll say okay well have fun with
that I guess I don't know what to do for
you I was and that'll go about my day
that's usually the way it works but
every once in a while
this uh randomly reignited outrage
provides me with an opportunity to
revisit or expand upon an important
point and that's that's what happened
yesterday when for some reason my
Twitter mentions became filled with
people upset over something that I
tweeted on March 8th
2018 and here's the offending tweet
this is this was me
um video games are a sacred cow because
our country is filled with adults who
are obsessed with them that's why we all
pretend insanely that there's nothing
wrong with or disturbing about a child
spending all day killing people in a
virtual world
shocking stuff
apparently in 2018 I made the
provocative claim that children
shouldn't spend all day playing violent
video games
lots of people apparently disagree they
I guess think that children should spend
all day playing violent video games
I mean I could see a response where you
say well no no kids played spending all
day playing violent video games
but to respond like you disagree with
the statements is another thing entirely
but that's what happened
now part of the reason why people dig up
old tweets is that it gives them or they
believe it gives them
a rhetorical Advantage because they can
pluck one statement from the past
completely remove it from the broader
context and conversation it was a part
of ignore everything else I may have
said about that subject at the time to
flesh out my views and instead they
could engage with this one statement as
if it was made in a void
you know it's a clever way to make a
straw man out of somebody's argument
even while quoting them directly
it may be a correct quote like I did say
that but it's only one part of a larger
thought
and the larger thought is lost leaving
only the one single piece that you have
isolated
for an example of how this works um
here's what a guy named George
alexopoulos who has a relatively large
social media following apparently here's
what he tweeted at me yesterday in
response to my tweet from five years ago
he said quote video games are a medium
not a genre you bearded puritanical
Philistine if your child is only playing
games where he's murdering people get
educated and buy him Minecraft rocket
League Mario Maker better yet play games
together and bond debate me Matt
he wants to debate me about this point
from five years ago now
um I'm a I'm aware that non-violent
video games exist
however in that one particular statement
five years ago I was specifically
talking about violent video games which
also exist
yes violent video games are a genre and
I was talking about that genre okay so
just because I'm talking about one thing
in particular it doesn't mean that I'm
denying that other things also exist
it's just that this is what I'm talking
about right now or what I was talking
about five years ago
um there was much more straw Manning
where that came from the quartering
tweeted quote the rights weird obsession
with disavowing video games anime and
social media is why they will never
appeal to most of gen Z the base is
literally dying off and most of the
voices in the community are actively
refusing recruits
well with all due respect to Jeremy from
the quartering I think it's safe to say
that I have recruited more people into
conservative conservatism than he ever
has or ever will
um I do sometimes you know I have to
admit get a little bit tired of hearing
lectures on Effectiveness from people
who are far less effective like at a
certain point these people need to maybe
take a second realize that
um maybe you could learn something
okay maybe you could learn something
from people who are achieving more than
you are in this fight
possibly
people are raving about genucel products
for example you might remember Jacob the
PA for my YouTube series where I was
forced to play video games I played
against Jacob in a game of Mario uh
rather Mortal Kombat and I completely
annihilated him well I ran into Jacob in
the hall the other day and I was taken
aback by how sickly and tired he looked
I'm obviously an incredibly caring
person so of course I asked if he was
okay thinking maybe he still hasn't
recovered from the complete
embarrassment of a middle-aged man
beating him well turns out Jacob just
hasn't been sleeping at all over the
last few days because he's been binge
playing the new Star Wars game that came
out now I was not only repulsed by his
face but also repulsed by him completely
by everything about him and utter
disgrace and unfortunately I can't cure
all the things that ail him but I can at
least cure the disgusting hideous
appearance of his face with genucel
nothing works like Jenny saw it's a
family recipe that's been perfected over
20 years Jenny cell promises immediate
effects you'll see results in 12 hours
guaranteed or your money back Jacob did
indeed see a medium assaults and he
couldn't be happier at least so I uh so
I hear since he's no longer allowed to
be in my presence but I hear that he's a
slightly less repulsive at this point if
you don't want to look disgusting try
genucel's most popular package for 70
off at genucel.com Welsh all orders are
upgraded to free shipping and every
subscription order includes a
complimentary spring spa box with free
spa Essentials go to genyourself.com
it's also at the very best a gross
oversimplification to accuse me of
disavowing video games and social media
you have me on the anime point however
as we all know I do literally think that
anime is demonic and every single person
who has ever watched it has become
possessed by the devil literally that's
what I think
uh but for the rest of it not so much
these were the most coherent and
intelligent rebuttals to my tweet from
half a decade ago most of the rest were
like these ah conservatives returning to
their cancel culture Roots feels like
the 1990s all over again don't be
left-wing don't be right wing have both
wings and fly
someone else said how is playing video
games any different than reading works
of fiction watching TV shows or movies
or any other form of fictional
entertainment I swear miserable people
just want others to be equally as
miserable as they are
another one says you can tell Matt's
parents didn't get him a Nintendo or a
Sega for Christmas when he was young
such a sad childhood he must have had
and someone else says the life of Matt
Walsh is empty you could end his life
and not a soul would mourn his passing
well
if you want to prove my point that video
games are a sacred cow in this country
and many adults are far too invested in
them than wishing death on me from
mildly criticizing some video games is
definitely one way to do it also also uh
same with the claim that a childhood
without video games must have been sad
as it happens I did have a Nintendo
growing up but most of my most cherished
childhood memories have nothing to do
with anything I played or watched on a
screen
you know I remember things like going on
hikes in the woods with my dad playing
kickball out in the backyard running
around outside all day in the summer
drinking out of a garden hose coming
back for dinner which which was always
homemade and we always ate as a family
around the dinner table those are the
kind of kinds of things that I remember
that's what I spent my childhood doing
how sad What a Sad childhood
yeah yeah all that stuff is great but
you didn't spend enough time playing
Mario
really sad
now we've heard from everyone who misses
the point but what is the point exactly
well there are a few points that matter
I think but you won't be able to hear
them if you insist absolutely that no
statements even vaguely critical of
video games can ever be uttered in your
presence okay if video games are a
religion for you then there's not much I
can say to get through to you but for
everybody else here's what it boils down
to
there's obviously nothing inherently
wrong with video games as a medium okay
just another form of screen based
entertainment and when it comes to our
children into ourselves too as adults
but we're just going to focus on
children for now
the two things we have to take into
consideration with screen-based
entertainment of all kinds are one the
messages embedded in the content and two
the amount of time spent on the content
now as to the first point yeah I think
all reasonable people understand that
the screen is a very powerful messaging
system there's a reason why the
corporate world spends literally
billions of dollars every year marketing
through the screen they know that it's a
very effective way to influence people
especially children there are plenty of
studies that prove this point if you're
into that sort of thing but you don't
need to study you're living in the study
you are the study we live in a culture
shaped by and around the screen go to
any school and you'll find a building
full of kids whose values beliefs
priorities tastes have been nearly
completely determined by the content
they spend their days in you know uh
ingesting through the screen
video games are not the only example of
this or even the most potent example but
they also obviously aren't an exception
they're in that category
they're all kinds of ideas and images
that kids encounter in astronomically
large quantities every day graphic
violence is one category you know it's
not good for kids to spend an exorbitant
amount of time consuming graphically
violent content even if the content is
fictional and virtual and imaginary
okay it doesn't mean that it has no
influence just because it's fictional
among other things it can have the
effect of desensitizing their minds and
their souls to violence
and the kind of casual cruelty and
violence that we so often see among kids
today
is a pretty good evidence of this
desensitization
like it kind of boggles my mind that
anyone could hear an argument he goes
you know kids are being dissensitive and
desensitized to violence then you hear
people say well what do you mean where's
your evidence of that where's my
evidence of it
look around you what are you talking
about you're living in the evidence
now this doesn't mean that kids should
never be exposed to any form of violence
at all violence is part of the world
it's not always bad either there's
heroic violence there's violence and
defense of the innocent and so on it's
good for kids to be given examples of
that kind of violence even if the
examples are sometimes fictional even if
they're cartoonish you know superheroes
for example are you know an example of
heroic violence but when the violence is
gratuitous and amoral and overly graphic
when it is violence for the sake of
violence when it's violence where the
entertainment comes from Simply watching
someone suffer even if in a fictional
context
that is when it becomes a problem
especially for kids that there's a
message in that kind of content too and
it's a message that undermines human
dignity and desensitizes the viewer
especially if the viewer is a child
so I think we should be very careful
about the kind of violence that kids are
exposed to whether it's through a film a
television a show a video on social
media
or a video game
second Point
um putting the quality of the content
aside which you really you really can't
do because the quality through all of
these mediums is so often garbage but
setting that aside
volume is the other great concern
whether we're talking about social media
shows movies or games kids are spending
a huge portion of their formative
childhood years staring at screens
they aren't having real childhood
experiences they aren't learning how to
relate to each other and to the world
they're becoming fat and depressed they
can barely even like speak to each other
they can't they can't look you in the
eye they can't they don't stand up
straight they're just staring on the
phone all the time
um and all of this can be traced back
to a life dedicated to these damned
screens
this is why we don't do video games or
phones or computers in our home with our
six kids it's not because we're afraid
they're gonna you know spontaneously
combust if they ever hold a phone in
their hand or play Minecraft or whatever
but it's because the screen
is a tyrant it demands obsessive
attention and it usually gets what it
demands there's an undeniable addictive
quality to all this stuff and most of us
know that from experience
you know it's possible to it's possible
to moderate your own usage it's possible
to moderate your child's usage of the
device it's possible to moderate the
kind of content they're exposed to on
these devices but the vast majority of
parents fail to impose that kind of
moderation and that's why it seems more
effective to us in my home uh and a sure
bet to Simply keep it all away for now
after all our kids will have a whole
lifetime in front of them to waste away
staring at screens if that's how they
choose to spend their adulthood I hope
they don't but they can if you know when
they're adults they can do what they
want
but they'll never be able to get this
time back they can never have a second
childhood as much as my generation might
try to pull that off for ourselves you
know trying to have a second shot you
can't actually do that
um our kids will have time for the
screens more than enough time
way too much time
for now I want them to have a childhood
and whether you let your kids play video
games or not I hope you don't allow the
video game or the TV or the phone to
become their childhood
that's the issue
and that's why ultimately it's the
parents who allow the screens to
dominate their children's lives who are
today canceled and I'll do it for us
today we'll talk to you tomorrow have a
great day Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]